listen listen go run okay I saw a
monster I love that you sung in the
movie you sung to but um are you guys
gonna be honest I hear you
that's right let me correct myself he
was signing okay because he wanted to
sing yeah yeah I wanted to sing in like
my next life believe I was carpool
karaoke maybe because you both saying I
want to do the first carpool dance
Donna's pool karaoke yeah I want to just
like I want to the car seems just I'm
not good at have a jacket I can't floss
it's I can't do it my son even when he's
being told off its flossing it's only
does go do Rummy's okay he's going and
you know stop laughing
I'm flossing I can't stop McKimson why
dad that's what he said why what's it
how's it I don't know I can answer that
question miss anointing so we should go
to them my moves
it's a lot of it's hip down oh I like to
be I like to be solid at the top I'm
light at the top and then the feet are
going crazy crazy legs but it's the
place impressing yourself she's like
dude I even know what's going on with
these legs James Corden and Channing
Tatum are literally getting cool dad
points for their new animated comedy
small foot oh look at you you're
adorable
are you guys so glad though that you can
do a movie that your kids can finally
see and enjoy
yeah yeah absolutely I mean if he just
doesn't like any memories at all
she doesn't think they're real movies
but yeah so she's hurt but it was really
cute though she she'd never she will sit
through anything that's scary stuff that
I'm like I don't wanna yeah she'll it's
crazy
but she did not like seeing me get like
I get there's a moment in the movie
where I get like tranquilizers started
or whatever she bout ran out of the
whole theater she shouldn't have in the
music nope I want to go I want to go and
I'm like it's okay it's okay yes it was
cute did she automatically recognize
your voice to your kids automatically
yeah cuz like that's I'm very silly in
this movie and that's basically how I am
with her so she really really I think
identify who are you gonna tell me your
kids have not seen the movie yet no no
they well my youngest daughter is only
nine months old but yes the my son and
my other daughter watched as a girl they
really really enjoyed it they absolutely
loved it my my son re7 was was really
taken with it and had lots of fair
questions afterwards and they were good
questions there the right question I was
then he got it they won that you want
kids to ask are after the film and
that's kind of the the greatest thing
about it like as a parent you never
quite know how to talk with your child
how that would work to watch you what
you tell them to do what you tell them
not to do which and the great thing
about this film is there is a a
wonderful message that runs throughout
the oh yeah which tells them to ask
questions and not be afraid and to
recognize our differences as actually
being something that is very very
positive and that's the thing that I'm
most enjoyed sitting with them and
watching
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]